what's popping variant it's me Mt and
Victor timely is noodles wait welcome
back to the heavy spoiler show by the
way it's great to have you but Victor
timely is noodles what the hell just
happened at the end of Loki episode 4
and what could possibly come next after
we just witnessed what looks like the
end of the entire MCU Multiverse as
we've known it well I believe that there
are actually hints from past Marvel
projects that could actually explain
What's Going On Here With a Little Help
from Norse mythology and creatively
applied science so let us dive into this
big banger of a cliffhanger together my
nerd babies now the sheer hype that I
experienced at the end of Loki episode 4
was astronomically High because I
strongly believe that what we just
witnessed was the next MCU Big Bang also
known as the initial Singularity if that
second term sounds familiar to some of
you it might be because you're a big old
science nerd or you heard Peter Parker
say at that one time in Spider-Man far
from home when being amazed upon
learning that the Multiverse exists
you're saying there's Multiverse first
because I thought that was just
theoretical I mean that completely
changes how we understand the initial
Singularity we're talking about an
eternal inflation system now for the
sake of breaking this down in as easy to
understand terms as possible you guys
ever watched the young Sheldon prequels
you know the Big Bang Theory if you have
then you're probably familiar with how
the theme song starts with our whole
universe was in a hot dense State then
over 14 million years ago expansion
started wait that in a nutshell is what
the initial Singularity is in science
the period of time right before the Big
Bang when all the energy and matter that
would ever exist in the universe was
crunched down into an extremely tiny and
impossibly hot dense state right before
that tiny Singularity explodes creating
the universe that we know of today that
is pretty much what I believe we all
just witnessed at the end of Loki
episode 4 the exact causation of the
next MCU Big Bang like that is what the
rainbow Infinity energies of the Sacred
timeline have always been in the MCU the
root rainbow energy energies that the
Infinity Stones were born from just
refined and woven into fine threads by
the time Loom of the TVA big bang and
six Elemental crystals huddling across
the Virgin
Universe these Infinity Stones each
control an essential aspect of existence
Marvel actually foreshadows this
happening at the start of the Loki
season 1 finale when we see the energies
of an entire universe get jammed
together in a singular hot dense ball of
light before exploding outwards again
and creating a completely new universe
and then revealing that this newly
created Universe all existed within this
black hole on the left of the frame here
that phenomenon that happens before we
zoom into this black hole on the right
is a representation of the cosmological
theory of the big bounce the big bounce
theory is essentially a theory that
proposes that the universe is in a
constant cycle of Destruction and
rebirth and at the end of our universe's
life all the energy in matter that ever
existed will be crunched together into a
super tiny hot dense space within the
center of a black hole an event
fittingly called the Big Crunch because
it's just a big crunch of all of that
energy which is then of course followed
by a new Big Bang this theorized endless
cycle of big bangs and big crunches is
called the Big Bounce and we literally
saw that happen in that black hole on
the left before we zoom into the black
hole on the right which shows us all the
energy that makes up the MCU Cosmos
being woven into thin pieces of energy
spaghetti to orbit around the Citadel at
the End of Time Guardians of the Galaxy
volume 1 actually includes a prophecy on
the walls of the temple room on Morag
that essentially tells us the story of
the initial Singularity and the cycle of
the big bounce specifically how the
combination of a high concentration of
six energies has triggered an endless
cycle of big bangs and big crunches for
countless eons if you guys want a really
great breakdown of this ancient prophecy
that also breaks down the science of all
the infinity stone energies check out
this super eye openening video on the
the Marvel trigger theory that you can
find right here however since that video
is several years old now I very much
consider that a first draft of a theory
that is evolved drastically since then
so some of the things that I do bring up
in that video aren't 100% accurate due
to me Having learned a lot more about
MCU Multiverse science since then
however despite this this video is still
a super solid primer that will get you
to see how Marvel Studios has
meticulously crafted their whole entire
Cinematic Universe with science I mean
since the MCU started with a science man
Kevin feige made sure to continue that
science theme throughout the entire
universe but I also highly suggest you
guys check out my Loki episode 1 video
on heavy spoilers explaining how the TVA
and the Citadel at the end of time are
located inside of a black hole because
I'm essentially just expanding on that
idea here in this video and if you do
you might also begin to see just how he
who remains has been preventing the
mcu's natural cycle of death and rebirth
by preventing the rainbow energies of
everything that has ever lived from
branching out and exploding by creating
the TVA and making his workers prune the
timeline for eons with this perfect
control over the TVA and his Mastery
over gravitational science he who
remains was holding off the natural
chaos of a new Big Bang beginning for
Everyone by shaping reality according to
his own will that is the prize of the
true winner of the multiversal time War
a seat at the center of the mcu's black
hole to manage the flow of Infinity's
rainbow energies that make up the flow
of time and all of existence these
rainbow energies are literally the core
of the MCU however when he who remains
got tired of managing all that energy
all the time he decided to let Loki and
Sylvie decide whether or not the next
big bang should happen with Loki being
on the side of the tva's unnatural order
and Sylvie choosing the side of natural
energetic chaos a decision that has now
led to the aggregation and amplification
of all of that energy inside of the
mcu's black hole doctor strange and and
America Chavez actually get a brief look
at all of the timelines wildly branching
from outside of the MCU multiverses
black hole in Multiverse of Madness
specifically right after they fly past
the faces of the living tribunals they
didn't know it at the time but they were
staring right at the black hole holding
sylv's chaotically branching sacred
timeline right before America and
strange jump into that timeline to start
crashing through realities like if
you're looking for an in-depth video as
to how America Chavez's Journey Through
the Multiverse works with her poers in
the context of this lowy black hole
check this video out that I did a while
back on another channel here but
speaking of trippy Doctor Strange
Journeys let's talk about the one that
the ancient on sent Doctor Strange on in
Doctor Strange one because that is the
first time that I believe we've seen the
initial singularity in the MCU if you
seen this Theory video that I made in
the past breaking down Doctor Strange's
Multiverse spell from Spider-Man no way
home then you'll know that I believe
that the ancient one sent Doctor Strange
on a Trippy Journey back in time to the
Big Bang event itself just so Doctor
Strange could experience what the inside
of the initial Singularity of the big
bang looks like before he continued his
journey through the Multiverse the
moment you need to focus on specifically
is when this black Vortex opens up
revealing a tunnel that doctor strange
floats down before colliding with this
big yellow initial Singularity and
finding a multitude of many Big Bangs
happening on the inside of that
Singularity symbolizing every Big Bang
that will happen in every universe but
anyways this all being said the reason
why we're witnessing the Rebirth of the
MCU within the context of a TV show
about a Norse god is because in Norse
mythology Lohi is directly involved in
Ragnarok and the subsequent end of all
things before the world is reborn and
the gods are reincarnated like I believe
the MCU has adapted that Norse myth in
their own science fictiony way through
the cosmically consequential actions of
two Loki variants in season 1 and season
2 of this beautiful program because ever
since the events of Thor Ragnarok
happened and the gods of Asgard fell
this marked the beginning of the end for
the MCU as we've known it because that's
what the asgardians prophesied would
happen following the triggering of
Ragnarok and like I've said in my last
two Loki videos on the channel I also
highly expect the sacred timeline to be
the mcu's adaptation of the Norse World
serpent known as yorman Gander an
unbelievably giant snake that is so big
that it is often depicted wrapped around
all of midgard while eating its own tail
a symbol that has shown up across
multiple cultures called the Ora Boris
and because because of the imagery of
the snake destroying itself to renew
itself the Ora Boris has become a symbol
of Destruction and rebirth which is
super important considering what just
happened in Loki episode 4 the sacred
timeline is just one massive Cosmic or
Bora snake with the time Loom acting as
the head of the mcu's multiversal
serpent adaptation of the mythical
yorman Gander a cosmic serpent that also
plays a significant role in the Norse
Ragnarok Story the theme of Ora boris'
is a big one this season especially
after episode 4 teas an Ora Boris like
connection between Victor timley and Ora
Boris your work is based on his work and
his work is based on your work exactly
which came first it's like a Snak eating
its own tail a connection that I believe
we will see explained by the end of the
season in a mind-blowing way I truly
believe that both Victor timley and Ora
Boris will end up becoming Mr Griffin
somehow those two are connected but
anyways because he who remains caused
the Ora Boris that is the sacred
timeline to explode and trigger a whole
new Big Bang the destruction of the old
Multiverse will now give way to the
creation of a brand new Multiverse where
all the energy and matter from the
center of that black hole at the end of
time gets shot outwards and
redistributed in a completely new way
but anyways what could this all mean for
Loki episode 5 well I think there are
two possibilities here the first of
which being that everybody at the TVA
except for Loki has been absorbed by the
energies of the big bang and have been
reincarnated into the new Multiverse is
next TVA possibly even the same early
version of the TVA where nobody body
remembers Loki and there are statues of
Kang littered everywhere Loki might have
actually visited this new TVA early on
when he was time slipping and because
that TVA is a new Multiverse entirely no
one knew who the heck Loki was now the
reason why I believe that Loki might
have been the only person in the TVA to
survive the blast from the Big Bang is
because Loki technically still has the
time stone that he pocketed in season 1
and the TVA removed the magic dampeners
right before the very end so I believe
that there was a chance here that Loki
used the time Stone to skip the Carnage
at the end of time and skip to the
beginning of the next Multiverse but
that's just one possibility but another
big possibility that could have happened
is that Loki could have transferred from
the black hole from the Loki season 1
finale on the right to the black hole on
the left because check this out gang I
have a feeling that it might be revealed
that he who remains could have been
balancing the energies of not just one
but two black holes this entire time the
two black holes from the Loki finale
like I've said in past videos if you
look at the windows of he who remains
his office you can see that his windows
appear to be designed after the black
hole that he lives inside with six
circles swirling around the center like
the six Infinity energies of the Sacred
timeline swirl around the TVA inside of
a black hole however if you look closely
at the entirety of his wall of Windows
you can see that he who remains has two
black hole styled windows that are
connected together through subtle lines
almost like an infinity symbol or an
hourglass this could actually be the
true significance of The Hourglass
symbolism of the tva's logo not just to
represent the managing of time but also
to hint that he who remains was
balancing the energies of two separate
multiversal black holes at the same time
which is why we can see one Multiverse
beginning and one Multiverse crumbling
and ending at the start of the Loki
season 1 finale because much like how an
hourglass spreads sand across two halves
there was a chance that he who remains
was Distributing Energy across two black
holes leading Loki to be cosmically torn
between two black holes through his time
slipping but those are just two
potential theories for how a Loki
episode 5 could even happen but the main
point of this video is to tell you guys
what we just witnessed at the end of
Loki episode 4 was the end and the
beginning of the MCU in my opinion
anyway the very origin of the Embers of
Genesis that was a focal point of the
chachala Star-Lord episode of what if
they're called The Embers of Genesis
nutrient-rich Cosmic dust from an
ancient Supernova with the power to
terraform entire ecosystems like the
very same ancient Supernova that the
Embers of Genesis came from likely just
debuted at the end of this episode but
only time would tell but anyways thank
you guys so much for watching this video
and hey if you guys want to see more of
me talking Marvel on the internet be
sure to follow the new podcast that me
and my friends just made called the
Guardians of the paly podcast we just
goof around and have a lot of fun while
talking about nerd so if that
interests you subscribe right now but
anyways you can follow me at
mastertainment on Twitter and Instagram
or wherever I am if you guys want to see
me post some weird but most
importantly follow heavy spoilers here
on YouTube because we got great stuff
for you all the time but yes thank you
guys so much for watching love you guys
so much and I'll see you guys later
goodbye